mares agitados vientos violentos
intensas lluvias mientras el huracán
'ida' soplaba a través de la isla de la
juventud en el oeste de cuba el viernes
por la noche miles de personas fueron
evacuadas mientras la tormenta arrancaba
árboles inundaba las calles causando en
su mayoría daños menores
pero la tormenta está ganando intensidad
a cada hora mientras se mueve hacia el
norte sobre las cálidas aguas del golfo
de mexico el servicio meteorológico
nacional de eeuu espera ahora que llega
a la costa del golfo como un huracán de
categoría 4 extremadamente peligroso con
vientos sostenidos de hasta 225
kilómetros por hora
el huracán 'ida' se ha convertido
rápidamente en un huracán antes de lo
previsto es más fuerte que el aura del
año pasado esta será una tormenta que
cambiará la vida de aquellos que no
estén preparados y listos para aguantar
lo que ida nos va a lanzar hogueras se
ha declarado el estado de emergencia en
todas luisiana los residentes está
abasteciéndose de alimentos básicos y
preparando las entradas a sus casas con
bolsas de arena para poder soportar la
tormenta y en la mente de todos los
enormes daños causados katrina en 2005
es como un déjà vú aquí viene de nuevo
no sabemos lo malo que va a ser todavía
no sabemos la altura del agua no sabemos
nada todavía todo lo que sabemos es que
está llegando en nueva orleans se ha
pedido a miles de recientes que evacúen
las zonas fuera de los diques las
autoridades dicen que las inundaciones
por las mareas de tempestad podrían
alcanzar hasta cuatro metros y medio
alrededor de la desembocadura del río
mississippi a la llegada de ida se suma
también el avance del huracán ahora que
se espera que se mueva hacia el golfo de
california el domingo y el lunes